the government knew last year that tower
blocks in Britain were being covered in
flammable cladding and that significant
fires showed it posed a risk but their
own fire safety advisors told them
Building Regulations were adequate the
Grenville tower disaster in which 79
people are thought to have died is being
blamed at least in part on flammable
insulation and plastic filled cladding
the fallout is widespread
this is Billingham on T side ministers
have claimed the cladding was banned and
it's now being stripped from buildings
across the country in what's been
described as a national emergency as of
midday today the cladding from 75
high-rise buildings in 26 local
authority areas has failed the combust
ability test the knowledge that
flammable material was being put on
tower blocks was in a report
commissioned by the Department for
Communities and Local Government by its
fire investigators bre global in april
last year they wrote an increase in the
volume of potentially combustible
materials are being applied to tower
blocks but concluded with the exception
of one or two unfortunate cases there is
currently no evidence that current
building regulation recommendations to
limit vertical fire spread of the
exterior of high-rise buildings are
failing in their purpose bre sets the
standards for fire safety testing in the
UK and has been involved with building
regulations since the Second World War
it is now testing the cladding being
sent in by worried social housing
landlords who thought the building
regulations were correct your
uncertainty what criteria they are
actually applying is it the same
criteria that the manufacturer installs
seeing we complied with all contemporary
building farm health and safety
standards
is the building research establishing
applying a new criteria more robust
criteria and it's also questionable that
they're only testing small-scale sample
meanwhile the chaos is spreading and
more buildings are being stripped of
cladding previously passed as safe this
is actually the biggest failure in
British construction history ever you
cut these panels over all sorts of
buildings commercial buildings hospital
buildings school buildings we don't
really know that the government knew
last year that people were living in
high-rise buildings covered in material
that burns
we'll turn attention to why their
advisers had confidence in building
regulations which have so tragically
been found lacking and why those same
advisers are now testing and failing
cladding taken from tower blocks which
past building control checks Jared tub
Sky News